hi in this video I'll be talking about
the memory T cells let's say our body is
invaded by a pathogen so after the
initial exposure of that our body will
mount an immune response and that immune
response is triggered by T helper cells
which would activate B cells and the
plasma cells would secrete specific
antibodies against that pathogen or
antigen right now after the primary
immune response the magnitude of the
response would dampen it down but
eventually if there is a second exposure
of the same pathogen then there could be
a secondary immune response which we
which would be lot faster and in terms
of magnitude would be higher and in the
context of secondary immune response
we'll be talking about the role of
memory T cell so whenever I say memory T
cell what quickly comes in your mind is
they are something which has a memory of
infection or memory of invasion of other
pathogens so they can really remember
that what what pathogen that they had
encountered previously and can mount an
immune response quicker and at a higher
magnitude so in this video we'll be
talking about how these memory t-cells
arise how the differentiate and what are
the subclasses of memory T cells also we
would focus on how by cellular and
molecular features we can discriminate
memory T cells from the affected T cells
or the naive T cells so let's begin
before that let's just go back to our
situation where our body is invaded by a
pathogen now obviously our dendritic
cells macrophages or any other antigen
presenting cells would be cheap would be
engulfing the pathogen and chewing the
antigens of the pathogen and displaying
it onto the class 2 MHC molecule which
would be interned recognized by our CDA
cd4 positive T helper cell now cd4
positive T helper cell can interact with
B cell and leads to B cell activation
now the B cell we
be converted or rather differentiated
into antibody secreting plasma cells now
these antibody against the pathogen
would neutralize the pathogen and save
our body from that attack right now just
after the attack the t-cell the naive T
cell would proliferate hugely in number
and once the attack is done and and the
pathogen is dead the mean response is
dampened and at the same time the
proliferated T effector cells would be
actually dying at least 98% of them
would die but this rest 2% or some of
them they don't die and people
hypothesize that these become the memory
T cell we'll talk about their origin in
more details okay now these memory T
cells are residing in a poisoned state
that means they are in a g0 state they
are proliferating right now from g0
State they are poised they can any time
reenter the cell cycle they can
proliferate and differentiate into other
effector cells so but there is a problem
because both naive t-cells and the
memory T cells are in g0 state then how
do you differentiate a memory T cell
versus a naive T cell it turns out the
reactivation criteria from a g0 state to
reenter the cell cycle is not less
stringent in case of the memory T cell
it is easy for a memory T cell to
quickly get back into the cell cycle and
proliferate and how is so we'll look at
that but and also it turns out that
maybe the naive T cell only take
stringent instruction from the dendritic
cell to get activated or reenter the
cell cycle whereas memory T cell the
thing is pretty much less stringent and
it can take information take the Intel
or the instruction from macrophages from
dendritic cell or even from the b-cells
so the criteria for reactivation is
easier in case of memory t-cell compared
to a naive t-cells now how this is
possible in molecule early it turns out
the surface distribution of the
receptors co-stimulatory molecules and
the adhesion based receptors are very
different in case of the memory T cell
it turns out that T cell receptor are
clustered in case of the memory T cells
which leads to a quicker and easy
activation and the distribution of all
these co stimulatory receptors are
different compared to our naive T cell
that leads to a easier activation when
it comes to a memory T cells now memory
T cells also display a property called
recirculation that means pain not only
reside in the secondary lymphoid organ
like the lymph node they can quickly get
redistributed to the tertiary lymphoid
organ or let's say the site of infection
that they have encountered previously so
their recirculation property makes them
different from a naive T cell now even
inside the memory T cell subtype there
could be different subtypes as well like
effector memory t cell or central memory
T cell but how does this differentiation
occur I mean what are the point of
difference the point of difference lies
in their localization especially the
effector T cell are localized to the
site of infection that they have
encountered previously now in terms of
surface marker expression and gene
expression these two cells are distinct
over a past decade with the increase of
with advancement of RNA seek technology
the single-cell RNA sequencing
sequencing technology revealed that the
gene expression the transcriptome
profile of effector T cell and the
memory T cell is completely different
now the reactivation potential is also
different between that and in turn
people hypothesize in the field that
these two cells are actually generated
from
a different differentiation state of a
affected t-cell we'll be talking about
that but what are these differential
molecules are the surface expression
molecules that differentiate the memory
T cells from other T cells so it turns
out the relative proportion of at least
three important surface molecule
differentiated differentiate these T
memory cells from other cell types they
are cd44 which is basically very
important for activations signals so
they actually increase the sensitivity
towards the activation signal 362 ligand
or say t-62 l is an adhesion molecule
which is important for encountering its
target and ccr7 is a chemical receptor
which is responsible for homing the
memory T cell into the secondary or
tertiary lymphoid organs now the
relative proportion of all these
determine what is the state of that
memory T cell either its effector or
it's a central memory T cell now their
origin what are the instructive cues
that allow differentiation of these
memory T's I mean this subtype of memory
T cell is still under debate but based
on existing data and model we can kind
of summarize what really happens and how
they theorize so here is our life T cell
which is interacting with the dendritic
cell right now for sampling the pathogen
derived antigen and it would be getting
activated and ultimately it would become
a effector T cell which will interact
later on with the B cells but this
process of naive t-cells two effector T
cell is not direct it turns out there
are several intermediate State people
call it several differentiation State
and it turns out there are certain
permissive cues which allow these
effector T cells to give rise to the
other type of memory T cell itself the
effector T cell can give rise to memory
memory cell but these intermediate stage
cells can also directly give to central
memory cell or effector memory T cell
and there could be an inter conversion
between the central memory T cell and
the effector memory T cell so this whole
network is pretty complex and less
understood but this is the overall model
that is believed in the field right now
so I hope you enjoyed this video and if
you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up and don't forget to Like share
and subscribe thank you